vous auriez fait dans la vie guillaume
genton certainement pas styliste et
mannequin maintenant mannequin on est
maintenant vous mannequin mais mannequin
comment leur en plastique qui dure
encore m'assurerai
de oued faire du mannequinat ouais on
vous a proposé de faire du mannequinat
ouais mais pour quelle marque mais en
fait alors que
j'étais en train de marcher dans la rue
on m'a dit ah je suis chasseur de têtes
ah oui caster sauvage ou donnez moi
votre femme votre votre mail et donc
j'ai reçu un mail et/ou et j'étais
sélectionnée pour un défilé c'était pour
le salon du chocolat
[Rires]
et le défilé très certainement vous
devrez faire un rocher a décidé il
s'appelait enrobés et gourmand ah oui
elle va très bien on va écouter donc
vous serez autorités 24 mai on est
réalistes que vous auriez fait
styliste style et c'est normal voilà mal
vous architectes architectes d'intérieur
d'extérieur extérieur d'extérieur bas
sortait
[Rires]
mais voilà pas ça pas dans toute
émission dure et son beau père
merci tiens vous qu'est ce que vous
auriez fait moi je reviens juste on
parle de minutes de cette petite pause
lecture du français
qu'est ce que c'est que cette poule à
non mais je voulais mettre un blouson
blanc l'a dit non parce que mathieu a
déjà un blouson bleu ce soir alors il a
plus de bouzonville votre veste on
dirait une best de moniteur d'auto école
de vaches non mais sans déconner si
lagardère oui c'est vrai quand on dit la
vérité c'est là c'est la styliste qui me
l'a donnée non ça moi ça c'est à vous
voulez acheter j'aime pas je passais les
mêmes boutiques
autre chose que ses adeptes est à
l'intérieur la marque
[Musique]
c'est toujours je sais pas du tout à la
caisse
allait pas mal allait bien mais alors le
problème c'est quelle vague va bouloché
comme mode easy
sa lutte à lui dire
juste vous vous avez pas vous coucher
tout de suite parce que
mais à travers nos directs et indirects
c'est à darron tu vas dire te dire bonne
nuit à
9 tout est neuf et ouais ça me parle à
personne
acheter ça tout ça ça vient d'être
acheté quoi ça
excusez moi mais ça y'a un magasin qui
vont dans des choses et fils de boire
dès
la première manche c'est ça oui mais
comment vous avez créé votre argent plus
tard il faut savoir quand tu arrives à
la boutique et tu es hors jeu j'ai
craqué à petit
c'est quoi cette boutique de pyjamas ces
éminences évident
tant il est vert voilà qui je suis là je
prends les choses chez damart passe à
maui trade a marre de faire la marche si
vous formiez me recevoir la marche alors
on va les voir là bas
alors c'est une fille situe pas si tu ne
papy brossard
achetez vous avez
vraiment ça
c'est une voix sait pas c'est pas mal
c'est pas nul hein
salut c'est avec ces coquins et cocasse
et cooking moi c'est tout transparent
aux différents qu'est ce qui se passe la
bague dira pas bon tu sais tu nous met
en vitrine vous mettez en vitrine
j'espère que maintenant vous allez être
quand même ça allait sortir des vitrines
sortait de la vitrine à maman alors vous
auriez fait quoi vous moi je les faire
footballeur professionnel
ouais c'est vrai qu'ils étaient très
forts en foot ils avaient l'air comme ça
mais dans les séries les plus forts que
vous bah oui dans la lutte
professionnelle notant au passage m je
vous souhaite empêcher les nerfs dans
les petites villes a fait sept ans au
bar
il était dans l'eau bfm
servez là bas ça aux cascades
séjour doit commencer maintenant c'est
aux côtés du trio
laid mais je suis capable de faire
énormément de cascades avec les gars là
ces cascades vous voyez l'escalier
qu'ont acquis qui va des ces deux
marchés semblant je sais j'ai pris
bélanger fait tout l'escalier à plat
ventre pas vraiment des goûts et youssef
izard venez passer un mois j'ai fini
tout rouge là j'étais toujours des jeux
fait débat car ça
a été décidé si tu étais très bon psg
pourquoi t'as pas aller en ligue 2 où
l'hymne national wazekwa non parce que
je pense qu'ils n'avaient pas assez de
talent il manquait quelque chose et j'ai
aussi un art un grand regret dans ma vie
c'est continuer à travailler je faisais
cariste en même temps que je faisais du
foot sécurité incident avait décalé
sénart cariste je fais je faisais déjà
des livraisons a maintenant je me levais
à 5 heures et le soir j'allais
entraînement déjà là je faisais déjà et
j'aurais dû peut-être arrêter à cette
époque là et à 20h45 et non
sur à coup nous intéressait vite et mon
fils par contre
pas rencontré par ai pleuré toute ma vie
c'est bon c'est bon comme vous allez
pouvoir
commencent à pleurer
avec moi que tu désires accueilli comme
ça prouve qu elle avait laissé à la
porte comme sa frondeuse et là je suis
passé je tends voiture toi ô pas mal le
souhait de la norme
[Rires]
elle est montée dans ma vols courts et
là ça fait combien de temps que tu re
avec moi pas mais va longtemps 7,8 à pas
comptés non elle est arrivée elle avait
26 ans
et ouais moi c'est comme les chiens les
années compte sept
a joué avec moi on connaissait et on
annonce
il en appelle à la santé
est aujourd'hui lé
qu'est ce que vous auriez fait ou
entités un antiquaire
que jamais du land mais vieux vêtements
ne
fais quoi moi j'aurais fait fructifier
mon physique
j'aurais été un chanteur
déjà fructifier votre code libre
j'aurais été youtuber à los angeles
c'est uber alles aujourd'hui c'est ma
ville d'auray vannes et tout maintenant
moi je retiens personnes
déjà les dix ans et que je suis jamais
allé moi c'est pas vrai ne suis jamais
allé mais non merci
bien que des surfeurs il perd gaulle est
magnifique et il y aura des surfeurs il
y aura sur six mois
toi le somme de rs malibu j'étais chez
moi là bas non besançon non mais
attendez quoi vous paradis ah ben oui
j'ai fait dix ans de rêve de ces soirées
de faire elle de fait louis bien sûr ses
voisins de johnny depp voilà
tout il se fait alors l'écho en fête ou
alors pas tout à fait mais on est commun
sur la mito ne
sais pas comment mais sur la mythomanie
mais en tout cas à los angeles
apparemment les critères ne sont pas
parents il ya un décalage non mais
sérieux j'espère vous étonne j'y suis je
sa méthode bah oui ça m'étonne je suis
jamais allée de match mais
comme vous acheter des maisons par part
sur
chabal hinchey jamais la loi 110 m haies
12 avril / photo les maisons je peux
virer sur photo
[Rires]
on les fait quoi alors moi j'aurais
adoré être avocate je suis fasciné par
nos études savait qu'elle avait 26 ans
et plus
mais s'ils ne sont pas dans ce sens là
[Applaudissements]
je l'adoré je suis fasciné par exemple
on aimerait partie incroyable présence
alors si
vous avez castaldi on avocat
l'avocat moi j'ai quinzaine d'avocats
qui tout tu te mets témoin lemonade
cette personne a volé et j'en possède
l'épreuve et la larible l'appareil
thaïlande
[Applaudissements]
vous avez en bus avec zéro répartis à
mais maintenant je le cultive mais
comment ça se fait je ne sais pas mais
c'est vrai à votre contact avant j'étais
drôle maintenant je triche
ap l'américain tulipa
avant ttpo va l'entériner donc voilà non
c'est la mer sont allons donc ne viens
pas me tuer
mais il a eu du talent non j'ai du
talent à faire ça maintenant le problème
c'est que moi donc c'est bon c'est vrai
que nous allons le voir je le cherche je
cherche pas du tout c'est parce qu'on
épouse ap par votre physique alors je
pense qu'il faudrait il remettra brender
en coûtera mais cette gare agha quoi
cette gaffe parce que c'est un ami ah ah
ah bon tu viens de voir ma jun 10 ha bon
ok voilà alors que diana qui choque que
daniel moreau qu'il faut pas s'arrêter
[Applaudissements]
à
ce que j'ai fait est mignonne mais j'ai
effectivement vrai oui sérieux c'est une
seule hockey et après tu remets rien en
retour après je te tue
je ne m'étais lenny kaye thomas
taylor tous se promet que sa miss que ça
va partir mais non c'est vrai j'ai abîmé
ta petite gueule avant de me plaisait
des gosses qui
attendait avec ça et avec ça ici
médecins dans la seule peut intervenir
jeu très complet des coffres pour
rachida rama
fait comme si mal comme tu m'as fermé
mais beaucoup
ta confiance
à
[Applaudissements]
jean paquette naturacam adoré mes potes
n'y a pas de coupe c'est un document est
mis à zéro bien méchant mais tes mains
dans le dos et
aux jambes alors basé à la base il dit
moi quelque chose qui m'agace
je suis comme castaldi j'ai pas de
répartie encore
[Applaudissements]
les dépenses et la
gentille a annoncé jean t n 4 et
christophe lambert
je ne sais pas pas de mal non adéquat
dans la rue il aurait fait preuve de
plongée ans de plongée abbas est vrai
que vous soignez me sous l'eau
[Applaudissements]
il a plongé maintenant il va reprendre
de plongée
ap christophe lambert dans ce bruit mais
oui les choses que vous c'est descendre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on se bat
comme vous auriez tes proches de
produits parce que j'ai mon diplôme de
plongeurs mais c'est beaucoup de
diplômes fait jamais rien aussi bizarre
les puissances travaillent trop
maintenant sa plongée pour vous libérer
non non non non mais également pour
s'enfoncer mais wu ping si j'ai ma carte
je suis plongeurs ces masques de bois et
les bouteilles s'était pas les
bouteilles de plongée qui vous
c'est une légende mais c'est quoi qui
t'empêche de le faire là tu parles
zodiac et de bouteilles d'oxygène
[Applaudissements]
quand tu sais quoi toi
non soit vétérinaire soit promoteurs bah
ouais bah c'est vétérinaire à ce
que ça vient d'imaginer les choses
pouvoir loger des gens est d'amener un
cocon j'adore ça il m'a dit les choses
avec guillaume genton n'ont jamais
rien comme ça va ensemble ils te plaît
son sweat avec mes chiens arrivent mais
alors est il un chien comme ça la maison
d'ailleurs dans mes lectures et argent
que je vais là-bas et l'autre au dos
vous savez
c'est 2010 20h28 on en direct
vient nous dire où là elle est donc déjà
guillaume genton elle est à chaque fois
qu'elle était plus à prouver et je doute
que ce soit pour une radio lac huelva
sur l'iphone
est imberbe
elle se fait lécher les pieds par son
chien et chaussures ça suppose quelques
heures laisse que le chien avec des
lunettes
[Applaudissements]
c'est le chat
allée des cheveux en jack
c'est possible le dauphin c'est la
personne tu vas quitter chez les payés
non mais j'annonce que guillaume a dû
les éduquer son chien de telle manière
que les filles à chaque fois enlève ses
chaussures enfin leurs chaussures ah
ouais ça va je pense aurait un petit
côté fétichistes et du coup quand
j'arrivais mes chaussures le chien me
bouffe les chaussures je suis obligé de
les mettre de côté une fois que je suis
pieds nus le chien dit plus rien et
ouais bah ouais ok voilà médicis non
j'aime pas un qu'est ce qui se passe ou
ça va
manquer alors donc elle est pieds nus
chez vous ouais ouais quoi alors quoi
parce que j'ai racheté un peu agressif
et j'ai fait une fixette sur cette
source ouais d'accord n'aime pas quand
j'ai les chaussures un peu voiture mais
m google c'est une belle anecdote moi je
suis chez lui m'a fait attendre dans le
garage
ah ouais je sais dans le garage par
contre
c'est qu'il n'a pas confiance en vous
vous auriez fait quoi vous alors c'est
drôle que me demandez pas ce que il ya
quinze ans je redis pilote de formule 1
mais aujourd'hui plus du tout maintenant
c'est plutôt à l'accueil du centre s'en
relever
on n'est pas bien c'est pas lewis
hamilton c'est lewis hamilton
je dirais fleuriste florrick si je suis
fou en ce moment de tout ce qui est
compositions florales
rhododendrons non si on est
habituellement sully profond alala
données en parle de fleury que quinze
jours par an alors c'est une bonne idée
pour un sac et m'éloigner de fleuriste
fleury je fais les compositions florales
pour des amis parfois pour des
restaurants
il a raison qu'il a raison franchement
favori je pouvais le faire non mais
c'est vrai que vous plaît chez vous si
vous voulez pour un petit contrat un bon
pour un montant toutes les semaines je
viens livrer des fleurs chez vous pour
ce joli alors c'est quoi mais où vous
avez des fleurs mousse et de faux badges
et rouge de laryngite pour les fleurs de
jeu oui oui bah prenez-moi de la viande
aussi rallié cgt
bout qui fait quoi c'était pas été
érigées milliardaire
tu parles à ce bout et les sandwichs
tartes à la crème il a bossé pour ça tu
nous tiens à bosser
bien sûr évidemment mais d'immenses
ringard
il était quoi si franchement oui le
champion de tennis trader
trader chinois
[Rires]
kemmer c'est maintenant un fait ça c'est
ça que tu voulais faire voilà si on est
là c'est vrai que quand tu vois tout ce
que tu as fait ou l'essec est ce que
dans cette ville depuis
20 ans c'est mon ami parce que vous
n'avez pas suivi depuis le débat bien
sûr donner des trucs sur lui que vous
connaissez pas mais je n'ai pas voir
comment ça le fun que telle était riche
en bons ballons mais c'est mon ami quand
va-t-on vraiment mais la cystéine
insisté d'insister voilà en brouille
avec des gens à 0 et maintenant les
mêmes genres toujours les bonnes gens
lui disaient ce que je peux me retrouver
avec toi et on a fait ça c'était écrit
toi vous avez commencé en même temps il
valoir
c'est mon ami j'ai suivi ma sur images
seulement j'étais derrière
cette étrange et sasha 9 ans était
derrière avec vous ça n'arrivera jamais
[Applaudissements]